hi everyone my name is sai venom and I'm
with the IBM cloud team now I know in
previous videos we've talked about
technical concepts that always relate
back to cloud native computing in one
way or another now over the years I've
seen businesses harness those concepts
to create innovative solutions to real
problems in this era of hybrid and multi
cloud businesses need a way to run
containerized applications in a way that
they can run anywhere in this video I
want to touch on a few of those views
cases but why a business may want to use
hybrid or multi cloud let's start with
the basic one cloud scaling now most of
us are probably familiar with this it's
one of the main reasons for adopting the
cloud now let's say we have a flower
delivery service that is able to hit a
certain bottom line of users to have
on-premise infrastructure and it can hit
a certain amount of user load so
visualizing this here throughout a
calendar year you can imagine that their
load maybe goes up and down and response
to specific holidays now to hit those
peaks they could scale up their
on-premise architecture but that's met
with upfront costs and cost of upkeep
now instead adult instead do is take
advantage of cloud that allows them to
scale up in response to that load and
then automatically deep provision
resources when they no longer need them
now this concept is kind of general to
cloud computing not just hybrid or multi
cloud but that brings me to my next
topic and here we're going to be talking
about how it can be used to build a
composite cloud so essentially this is
going to be applications that are spread
across multiple cloud environments so
back to the flower delivery service
let's say they have on-premise
architecture that allows them to run
three major components of their app so
let's say they have the web UI they have
some billing api's as well as a rewards
framework
now let's say that this service is
actually based in EU and their European
customers are happy but for their North
American or American customers it's best
specifically around you know Veterans
Day or Thanksgiving they're noticing
that the system is bogging down and so
they decide to take advantage of a
hybrid cloud or multi cloud architecture
by composing their application across
multiple cloud environments so they'll
take advantage of data centers in
America and essentially they've
identified that although the rewards
framework can stay on prem in their
european side they want to move the
billing and the UI capabilities over so
they'll move just those two to a cloud
platform of their choice in a north
american or american data center this
kind of allows them to scale up portions
in response to say american holidays
while keeping their EU portions
individually scaled so in this example
the flower delivery service is able to
take advantage of scaling at a global
level by using the hybrid or multi cloud
architecture next let's talk about the
airline or travel industry so we can
first start with an example of
modernization now in the past we've seen
that you know reservation systems may
have been difficult to work with or you
might have had to call in but almost all
all the airline companies now have a
mobile application so most of the time
and we've actually found that it's about
in general not just in that travel
industry but 80% of all enterprise
applications are actually still on prem
and that's likely the case in this
industry as well so in this specific
example let's say they have a
reservation system that's running on
prem but to create new experiences for
their end-users let's say they've
created a mobile application that mobile
app of course has a mobile backend
that's maybe running in a public cloud
and that in turn works with the
reservation service so again the mobile
hub can hit the mobile backend and
works with the reservation capabilities
so in this case they've modernized and
new user experiences are possible but
let's take that a step further now a
source for a lot of dissatisfaction for
users is whenever their flights are
delayed so when a flight is delayed they
may have to rebook new flights the
solution is almost always the same the
traveler wants to get to his destination
in the easiest way possible so what
airline industries have been doing is
taken advantage of the cloud to create
maybe a recommendation feature so it
allows them to book new flights as soon
as the delay is recommended or as soon
as the delay is incurred and that's
going to connect up to that mobile
backend service allowing users to be
able to book flights through their phone
the second of flight is delayed this not
only improves the bottom line for the
airline industry leads to happier users
so that's one way the modernization has
been done next let's take it even a step
further and talk about data and AI for
data in AI the airline industry has been
taking advantage of lots of historical
data so over the decades that a company
has been around let's say they have
historical data of when unplanned
maintenance has happened on on their
airline in fact 30% of all delay time
and that in the airline industry is
actually when unplanned maintenance
happens so by taking advantage of let's
say machine learning or AI capabilities
they could hook into all of the legacy
data that they have large volumes and
connect them up to machine learning and
AI capabilities this allows airline
industries to take advantage of
predictive analytics and get insights
before errors or before the unplanned
maintenance ever occurs this again
improves their bottom line leading to
happier users and a more efficient
airline industry now today we talked
about four major use cases for hybrid
and multi cloud platforms so cloud
scaling and composite cloud in the
flower delivery service as well as
modernized and data and AI for the
airline industry now if you like this
video or have any questions be sure to
drop a like
or a comment below be sure to subscribe
it's stay tuned for more videos like
this in the future